apple is in serious trouble and you
might be as well if you want a new mac
in this video we're going to talk about
what exactly is going on what you could
do about it and how we got here along
with if we are going to be having issues
with new macs that are rumored to be
announced at wwdc and if we might get
delays late last summer we made a video
on why apple is immune to the global
chip shortage that was very detailed
showing off how instead of having 50
less inventory than demand with certain
brands and sales going down because they
couldn't get chips apple instead was
able to not only provide as many macs
and devices as people could buy they
actually were doing discounts on them
for example selling the macbook air that
is super popular for as low as 850
dollars that absolutely destroyed
windows competitors that cost a thousand
two hundred and that weren't even
available but now nine months later
everything has halted and flipped and
we're having some major issues now were
we wrong about this video no
not at all and i'll explain why when the
world went into chaos and the ship
shortage started apple made some very
smart moves first off they went to a
live stream event in very short notice
started producing very high quality
videos and they actually made more
events than they did previously while
spacing everything out and not only that
one massive advantage they had compared
to companies like dell is that they
switched from intel which were
struggling to make 10 nanometer chips
and providing chips to apple to their
own apple silicon chips that not only
allowed them to have much better devices
than the previous intel macbooks for
example macbook airs that came out just
half a year before that but at the same
time they were able to have enough chips
produced by tsmc just because of the
amount of chips the apple can order and
the guaranteed orders that tsmc can rely
upon along with that they really focused
in on work from home and providing
products that people could afford and
are very usable by starting out with
updating their lower end lineup and they
made a very smart move they took this m1
chip that they marketed like crazy and
they put it into a bunch of devices
because they could actually manufacture
this chip so not only did you get it in
max and then coming out with the imac
six months later but they're now putting
it in the ipad pro and even the ipad air
taking advantage of their ordering
capability and the good yields for this
chip now this resulted in massive
profits for apple quarter after quarter
they're making huge amounts of money
with crazy sales in this environment
where other companies can't even get
enough chips to make the laptops and
other products that they want to sell
and in fact the recent quarter that just
ended had record-breaking earnings and
profits with increases in all of their
products but one
and now here we are just a few weeks
later and apple is sitting here with
only three macs that you could buy and
get right away
so what is going on well first off let's
see what is actually available the first
one is a 13 inch macbook pro you can get
one today you can pick it up in store or
get fast shipping but this is the laptop
that we've been telling you guys for
over a year now not to buy so it looks
like you guys are actually listening
because it's not a great value overall
the second mac is the 24 inch imac now
we actually really like the imac but
it's a consumer focused product and one
that is limited to the desk so you can
go pick one up right away that one is
available but most people would rather
have a laptop that they could actually
take with them as well and the third mac
is the mac mini this is another great
mac but this is the one that should be
replaced at wwdc with the redesign and
possibly the m2 chip so those people
that have not yet bought one that are
into macs like this well it's actually a
good reason to not buy and wait now if
you want to buy our favorite macbook the
macbook air which is such a killer deal
you actually have to wait up to two
weeks to get one if i want to go pick
one up at the apple store it's actually
two and a half weeks away and that is
the base model that is kept most in
stock if i want to make a smart choice
and upgrade to 16 gigs of ram for
productivity well then that is almost a
one month wait for a product that you
could literally go on amazon previously
and not only get it with one or two day
shipping but you could actually buy it
for as low as 850 bucks and if we look
right now we literally don't even see
the base model listed at all if you want
to pick one up you have to go for a
higher end configuration and even
possibly over pay above msrp to get one
now i also did a search on craigslist
and facebook marketplace and i didn't
find any legitimate listings at all when
you could previously find one now this
is not only an issue with the macbook
air if you want to buy that macbook pro
there's also shortages and say if you
want to buy a mac studio which we really
loved you could be waiting up to four
months to buy one of these so what do
you do do you wait up to two and a half
months for a base model 16-inch macbook
pro or do you just wait till wwdc and
hope that we get new macs or are there
other options and why is this happening
well let's jump into that
first off as far as the chip shortage
apple is not having a huge issue with
chips now yes some of these chips like
the almond ultra they are in high demand
but if we take a look at tsmc they have
had not as many issues as other
companies and as far as outbreaks and uh
current people getting sick well taiwan
has had very little issues they've been
one of the most successful at having
control so as far as production of the
actual chips these amazing m1 m1 max mn
ultras
there is not a huge issue now the bigger
issue that is happening is china itself
where these macs get put together and
shipped out of if you guys have been
following along china's had a zero
coveted policy where they want to shut
down all cases and because of that a lot
of different companies have been shut
down including factories that produce
apple products for example after recent
outbreak iphone city went into a full
lockdown in apple's proactive plans to
hire people for iphone 14 ahead of time
were cancelled now there were a couple
things that apple was doing to keep
production going for example using
closed loop factories where employees
would actually stay in the factory and
not leave in order to not have any
outbreaks but still continue working now
this was going okay for a while but it
actually ended up with a huge issue
where employees broke out of there ended
up getting into fights with security
guards and just having this massive
exodus which is now causing these issues
where the people that need a new mac
they want to use it for work or for
whatever reason you're not able to get
one and we're having massive chore
shortages not because of the chips
themselves but because of production
shipping and other issues so what should
you do should you buy a 13 inch mac pro
that is available in stock not only that
you can actually pick up a renewed one
for 900 bucks on amazon
instead of you know the regular 1200
well i don't think so i think it's
probably better to hold off possibly to
wwc but we also have a couple other tips
first off if you're looking at certain
best buys they still have stock in store
that you can go and pick up at regular
price also costco's have some stock
depending on your location but that is
going very fast the other option is
apple refurbished people have been using
this to save money for many years now
and right now you can not only save some
money we actually get and get some of
the product now if we go ahead and go to
the macbook air which is the most
popular things are going fast when i
first started researching for this
there's actually six models listed now
there are only two and they're not the
base models now you will pay a little
bit more for example 1059 here but you
are getting some extra options for
example you're getting a 512 ssd for
this one uh and you are still saving
money compared to the msrp price and
you're also getting the a core gpu now
if you do want to go this route you
should do it quickly because they are
going and for example if we go to the
macbook pro all we see here are the
older 13 inch models none of the 14 or
16 inch models apple did start selling
on their refurbished website recently
but now they are all sold out now with
everything flying off the shelves this
quickly and even used listings being
non-existent
that has me worried about wwdc
now in a recent video we talked about
new incoming macs coming out for example
we have the mac mini that's supposed to
be redesigned we have a macbook pro that
could come with the m2 chip but with the
same chassis and of course the one that
we've been waiting for the macbook air
that's gonna be a first redesign in a
while it's gonna be such a hot selling
laptop and it's something that a lot of
people are waiting on but for me
personally my thoughts are
if we are having such issues with
production in china and we're having
these um limitations and stuff selling
so fast does it really make sense for
apple to launch a brand new product
right away if they actually can't make
even the older ones that are already at
efficiency for production now we have
seen over the past couple years where
things kept getting pushed back for
example apple changed up their tick tock
cycle on their budget ipad and instead
of actually changing the chassis going
to a larger size like they're supposed
to they just made an easy upgrade
internally just by switching out the ram
and the chips and the camera and then
also the oled for the ipad air that got
pushed back as well because of shortages
and even the ipad air 5 itself instead
of getting the changes that it was
supposed to have for example getting the
external flash just like the ipad mini 5
they didn't do that at all and they just
literally made the internal chip change
to the m1 which is the easiest change
that they could have made of course with
that the 16 inch macbook pro had delays
by about half a year instead of june
time it came out in the fall the imac
was pushed back
and so with all these kind of delays in
this global
economy and what's happening right now
we've talked about in previous videos
will apple really put out a bunch of new
macs now personally we hope that they
will but once again it is wwdc
which is a software conference and we
have had multiple years where we had
rumors of stuff coming out but then it
turned out to be just a software focused
event now at the same time we do know
that we are going to get some really
great software updates at wwc
specifically for ipad os and if we take
a look not only do we have tons of stock
for ipad pros and we have the new ipad
air 5 but apple is actually doing some
great discounts on those items because
they are available the production is
great and even the brand new 2022 ipad
air 5
with the m1 chip that thing is actually
now 554
so you can buy it in stock for shipping
right away and you can get it at a
discount so
if we do have some changes and we have
new software for ipad os making a much
better computer it would make sense to
kind of push these products especially
because the ipad is the only category of
products apple selling that actually
went down in sales compared to
everything else booming so you guys let
me know your thoughts is this a big deal
to you what do you think is going to
happen in wwe dc we hope that the rumors
are still going to come true we're going
to get these new macs and
everything is going to go well and kind
of calm down thank you guys for watching
check out one of those great videos
right over there click above to
subscribe to help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers this is max and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]